hello friends how are you guess what
time it is it's project for awesome 2013
mean I'm kind of in shock that I'm
making this video again that it's
already been a year since I've made the
last one this is by far my favorite time
of the year because it's where the
YouTube community nerdfighters every
youtubers little community all gets
together and becomes one amazing group
of people so again for this year I will
be supporting charity water as I have in
the past few years if you guys aren't
aware we have raised over 27,000 dollars
for charity water and what's so cool
about this is there's actually photos
there's GPS locations there is a proof
of how many people we have helped just
by donating a few dollars water is such
a small thing that all of us take for
granted but when you don't have clean
safe drinking water what do you do
you
we're trilling the village in Ferrara
450 people with now the drillers they
found clean water 150 feet underground
in about a week everybody here is going
to be drinking clean and safe water the
rig will go on to drill a tee well and
help 40,000 people every single year
now we're going to keep going until
every single person
clean and save water to drink thank you
all so much continuing to make this
possible
so if you guys aren't able to donate
that's okay but any little bit will help
the link is in the description so make
sure you guys check it out also post
links so you can see some of the past
projects that we fund it it's kind of
cool to be able to go and see what you
guys have actually helped create not
only that make sure you guys like this
video make sure your favorite make sure
you comment and not just on my video any
video that you see that is a project for
awesome video be sure to go and show
your support and spread the amazing
project for awesomeness throughout the
YouTube community if you guys want maybe
you can even share it on G+ thank you
guys so much for all of your support i
appreciate it so much especially for
this because it really means a lot to me
and i love to be able to actually
physically see the people that we have
all helped together so all of my
internet friends i love you guys thank
you so much and don't forget to be
awesome why I now have a couch to catch
me when I fall